hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger sur toutes les chaînes
j'ai pris moi j'ai fait un petit dossier
qu'on va déposer semaine prochaine
keskia benhaim alors nulle trace aussi
c'est pas possible partout qu'il a fait
rire en bourse
[Rires]
donc ce petit jeu je vais vous placez
parler vrai partout poussent vous
porteriez pour moi merci ben voila merci
sophy bon alors d'affaires du bénin
simon a perdu regardait les deux hier
soir face à face de fous rires
regardez mon ami dj bizarrement je
l'appelle par exemple les éditeurs pour
vous proposer des livres
les éditeurs de paris flammarion les
éditions de minuit
et quand je leur dis que s'est
poursuivie la nina au départ
[Applaudissements]
trois temps la face à face il qu'on
appelle les donateurs pour leur dire je
travaille avec civile adidas et qui agit
pas l'occasion à m donc quand vous
appelez vous eu peur ils vous
connaissent pas vraiment en fait
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'appelle les gens à bayac jean-pierre
bon compte mais vraiment fait mal ce
décret en fait ils pensent que c'est un
canular
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en revanche je trouve ça parfaitement
stupide alors si vous vous changer de
sexe voilà gras dur si vous deviez vous
devenez une femme qu'est ce quelle est
la première chose que vous feriez vous
rêvez de faire quoi en tant que femme le
doigté quoi me doigté
[Applaudissements]
et tu m'as tu m'as demandé d'être ans je
suis marié mêmes gens me et pompiers toi
mais tout le monde aurait fait ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est moi je vous en supplie déplorer à
laver sans déconner et qu'est ce qui est
drôle c'est pourquoi il ya un cours
d'eau loriette le ton pour que cette
guitare avec lui et dans le calendrier
des dieux du stade met au dessus en très
bonne mais je vais pas vous plantez fait
tous les mois ouais je suis partout
avril septembre à décembre
surtout van damme elle aurait fait une
danse endiablée agile et apparemment ils
ont commis l'irréparable on a retrouvé
la photo de leur fille yula la regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la préquelle côté lyon date c'est plus
désobligeants
[Rires]
non mais c'est elle et pas du tout elle
n'est pas français je suis empressé de
le faire venir dont là je vais je la
connais pas j'ai passé le issa cissé lui
alors attendez est-ce que tu n'aimes de
pouf mais oui vous pensez bien sûr alors
au menu soupe assez bien sûr alors
[Rires]